Shammi my Begum was stripped of her
British citizenship last year the
government said she was a national
security risk and also had Bangladeshi
heritage the Bangladesh said not our
problem
Begum was left stateless she was
interviewed by Sky News around that time
from the camp where she is still being
held on the Syria Iraq border I think a
lot of people should have like sympathy
towards me from everything I've been
through you know and I all right I
didn't know why I was going into and I
left and I just was hoping that maybe me
a foot sick of me and my child
let them come back today three High
Court judges agreed that she should be
allowed to return to the UK to appeal
her case in person this was the reaction
of her legal team MS Begum has never had
a fair opportunity to give her side of
the story a statement said Ms Begum is
not afraid of facing British justice she
welcomes it but the stripping of her
citizenship without a chance to clear
her name is not justice it is the
opposite but Sajid Javid who as Home
Secretary removed her citizenship
published a statement of his own
justifying his decision limitations in
UK law mean there would only be a small
chance of a significant prosecution for
crimes committed in a foreign war zone
and regardless of the final outcome of
her case if miss Begum does come to this
country it will prove impossible to
subsequently remove her Shamima Begum
left her home in East London and
traveled to join Islamic state with two
school friends in 2015 they got on a
plane at Gatwick to Istanbul and then on
to Raqqa in Syria she married a Dutch is
fighter and they had three children
together all of them died she by her own
admission has been exposed to Islamic
state and its horrors this will be an
issue for how the police and the
security services manager when she
arrives here she has she's gone there
she's been with Isis they'll want to
make sure that there's significant
limitations on internet access as you
can see where
Tagg she'd be required to have a curfew
the Home Office called the judgment very
disappointing and said it will appeal
Shamima begum isn't going anywhere just
yet
alistair bungle Sky News